so what is it that we are really
fighting well I think RFK really kind of
nailed it right here and then none of
these big tech companies allowed anybody
to read the laptop story in the weeks
leading up to that election now to me
that is our government in this case
through the FBI putting cinder blocks on
a scale of an election is that something
you would stop and do you agree with me
yeah I would stop that in fact I'm going
to issue an executive award at the
moment I get into the White House the
first day for bidding
of ending the weaponization of our
agencies for political purposes
it's worse than it's ever been my my
view it's worse than it's ever been and
you know one party will be in power and
then they'll start doing it to the other
party and of course back and forth all
right so what defines this new please
you name it group
that includes you if you're watching
this this new Coalition this thing
that's trying to take shape it's ending
the machine and the agencies and their
collusion with big Tech and their
assault on the First Amendment their
assault actually on the Second Amendment
their assault
really on all of our foundational
documents and our right to live as we
see fit
[Music]